I am a cane cutter and I talk about
relationships and I just feel like as
men with dealing with females it's a lot
of stuff that we want to say but we
can't say because we're afraid of losing
whatever it is that we want from a
female you know what I'm saying so I
just consider myself the everything that
a guy really wants to say just unbuilt
it I like to call myself a well
calculated [ __ ] I'm not I can never
be an [ __ ] to you and not be able to
explain my [ __ ] dismiss if that makes
any sense like I can I can tell you I'm
being a dick right now instead of saying
be quiet I say shut the [ __ ] up you know
what I'm saying you I can explain why
I'm telling you to shut the [ __ ] up
instead of be quiet you know what I'm
saying most girls I mean most guys that
gotta say something like that today
girls just saying it because they want
to say it like everything that I do
everything I say has a reason and I feel
like if you can explain if I can make
you see my point of view then you'll be
more receptive to what I'm saying you're
understanding the girls don't have to
have a filter you know what I'm saying
like a girl if like we win like we in
the office right now if a girl walked up
to you and said I like the way you dick
look at them jeans you know I know what
you wanna do go to human resources and
snitch you know it's not gonna work you
know girls I have to have a filter but
if you go up to it and then say you know
your titties look nice today you say pee
all over that sexual harassment you know
I'm saying so girls don't have to have a
filter but we do because that's just
that's just the way it is you know what
I mean but my whole thing is why can I
say what I really want to say to you
anytime that we do something they always
gotta justify why we doctor I feel like
that's why guys are so good at
explaining their [ __ ] because we
always put in a position where we have
to explain myself but we always on
defense like when you first meet a girl
you know that she tells you I only been
with two guys and you say oh I only been
with
three girls she doesn't believe you just
because you're a guy you know that don't
sound right but I'm supposed to believe
you right off the bat be just because
you're a girl and you know I got a trust
that you won't lie but we always in a
position where we got to constantly
defend myself you know we just start off
on a bad foot so I just feel like it's
not there and everything that I feel
everything that I say is the same way
that every guy pills every guy feels the
same way that up there when I talk about
certain situations and certain subjects
and stuff like that so yeah it's not
there the girls that embraced me they
can they look past that you know the
name-calling they pay a table they pay
attention to the message you know what
I'm saying those those are the fans that
I like the female audience that I like
that that can get over all the the
name-calling and all other stuff to
actually hear the message stop hearing
what you want to hear and hear what I'm
saying you know what I'm saying to get
past skip pass all look at the [ __ ]
and hos and so that's the way that I've
talked the way not talking my videos is
the way guys talk to each other you know
what I'm saying so that's that's the way
I look at my cameras one of the homeboys
was talking to about whatever I'm
feeling you know I mean so I don't feel
like I have to edit myself or I have to
not say certain things because I'm
scared to lose people around us like
what do you want to eat leave you know
what I'm saying so I and the thing that
gets me is people are complaining
comments but you still watch my videos
so you know yeah whatever it is [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] the [ __ ] one
[ __ ] - [ __ ] oh [ __ ] new [ __ ] because
this [ __ ] you about that [ __ ] and that
[ __ ] you about this [ __ ] none of these
[ __ ] to be upset because each [ __ ]
would already know that she ain't the
only [ __ ] I know at the beginning when
I started making videos and once I
started to get popular I started to be
conscious of you know some of the things
that I was saying or my subject matter
and stuff like that but after a while
you you get to that point where you got
to remember who are you who are you
doing this for in the first place you
know I'm saying I started YouTube
because I like to make videos I make the
type of stuff that I would want to see
if I wasn't creating content I just feel
like anybody that wants to open up or
anybody who's afraid to to not say what
they want to say because he might lose
people just you gotta let that go the
bathroom has good light that is the only
reason I shoot
only reason I shouldn't bathroom but
have I ended up in the bathroom that's
where I was and it just just kind of
stuck and then it it kind of helped me
out because people say yeah you see how
you ever hide a my rock and then to be
able to got it makes the videos in the
bathroom so it kind of it kind of goes
hand in hand now so people expect to see
me in the bathroom when I make a video
so but yeah it just had good light
that's not the reason I got in there I
really I really don't know the way that
my little writing process if I I stand
in the mirror and I just I just start
talking and stuff that make me laugh I
write it down now see I don't use it for
a video soon the good head concept was
just completely just hours of talking
myself and in the mirror and then that
idea came up same thing with the Builder
[ __ ] workshop t-shirts this how great
would it be if you had a place you could
go to to just build your your perfect
dream woman you can get that [ __ ] in
black you can get that bitchin white but
most importantly you can get that [ __ ]
pizza piece I was like my first real job
so it was Pizza Hut it was working at
nursing homes
I was driving disabled people around I I
worked at Burger King for a day and quit
and just like [ __ ] Burger King you put
the burger through the Machine and then
flames and [ __ ] start coming out top and
I was like it's probably not gonna work
why am I here you know you just you look
around oh my god I'm not staying at
breaking so I went back to pizza like
that was any better place yeah so one
day I'm very King I was finished I was
signed with maker before I got with our
big frame and I really didn't have
anything bad to say about me but when I
got into the whole YouTube game and
heard about being a partner and then you
want you a partner dinner you join a
network how just don't you thought yeah
I'm not what I thought you were supposed
to do next you know those those ABCD
steps and when I was with maker like I
said I have nothing bad to say about him
but um they told me that the resources
were there if I needed him but I do
everything myself so I never really you
know had that relationship with my maker
so you know I just thought you join a
network for the sake of saying that you
and what a network and then a big frame
approached me and you know they really
believed in what I was doing and
wanted to they asked me you know what my
end goal was in mind and they've just
been doing everything they can to try to
get me to that step and what I like
about big frame is just it's real
family-oriented and Ashley she's she's
like my manager or whatever you want to
call it so uh I taught that at least two
or three times a week you know what I
mean and it's not even always one
business it's just hey you good you need
anything everything good you know it's
stuff like that so it's just it's just
real family-oriented and it really feels
like home you know so I feel like if you
join a network you need to think about
what can they do for you you know you
gotta think about your end goal and what
they can do to help you get to where you
want to be you know what I mean so I
definitely feel like big brain is a good
fit for me I really want to be idea just
for the simple fact that I want to get
into acting you know so I just feel like
Cali and be a move that definitely I
would definitely have to make sometime
in the near future you know what I'm
saying but the only thing that's really
stopping me right now is I just I just
want to make sure that it's a logical
decision before I come out of it because
you know dreaming is one thing but I
want to have a game plan and I come out
here but so I just I just need to
formulate a game plan before I actually
make the move so that's really the only
thing over the back right now I really
want to get into acting you know what I
mean that's that's always been what I
really wanted to do I always tell people
comedy happened by mistake but somewhere
down the line I do want to get an act
and YouTube I don't I don't know if I
would be completely done with it
you know what I mean I can see myself
slowing up because other things are
starting to pick up you know what I mean
but I don't see myself ever leave it
alone completely
I'm Kang kata Aki damn our optimum check
me out at youtube.com slash hi there my
rock facebook.com slash chop them all
right
everything had their mo rock with a boy
in the viewer he's behind the scenes
stuff that water cool or whatever [ __ ]
check out new media new media rockstars
right yeah you media right stuff so
thanks